un compuesto mes o es un compuesto que
tiene centro espirales pero es a tirar
vamos a volver a esta definición en
pocos minutos
ahora vamos a centrarnos en este dibujo
nuestro objetivo es dibujar todos los
estéreo isómeros posibles para esta
estructura de puntos sabemos que este
carbono es un centro quiral y también lo
es este esperaríamos tener dos a la n
estéreo isómeros donde n es el número de
centros finales y ya que tenemos dos
centros espirales aquí esperaríamos que
haya dos a la segunda potencia o cuatro
estéreo isómeros esto representa
solamente el número máximo de story
someros así que lo voy a poner entre
signos de interrogación tendremos cuatro
estéreo isómeros dibujemos las cuatro
posibilidades nuestro 1er estero y
somero podría tener ambos promos
saliendo hacia nosotros en el espacio
voy a dibujar eso
podemos tener los dos pero vamos
saliendo hacia nosotros y para la
segunda posibilidad podríamos tener los
dos promos lejos de nosotros en el
espacio
aquí están los bromas alejándose para la
tercera posibilidad podríamos tener un
bromo acercándose
y otra promo alejándose
y para el cuarto simplemente los
dibujamos al revés el bromo de arriba
voy a dibujarlos lejos de nosotros y el
bromo de abajo queda cerca de nosotros
examinemos las relaciones entre nuestros
estéreo isómeros y vamos a empezar con
los posibles y estéreo isómeros 3 y 4
vamos a compararlos y veamos qué
relación tienen uno con el otro aquí
está el estéreo y somero 3 podemos ver
que hay un bromo hacia nosotros y un
bromo lejos de nosotros del lado derecho
está el estero y somero 4 con un bromo
lejos de nosotros en el carbono de
arriba y un bromo que va hacia nosotros
aquí comparemos nuestros estéreo
isómeros sigir al de la derecha podemos
ver que estos son imágenes especulares
uno del otro si trato de superponer uno
encima del otro consigo que un par de
bramos queden alineados pero el otro par
no coincide si quiero alinear al otro
par de bramos ahora el primer par no
coincide
estas son imágenes especulares no
superponibles son en antiguo meros
así que 3 y 4 son en anti o menos son
imágenes especulares no superponibles y
podríamos haberlo sabido examinando el
dibujo porque en este carbono hay un
bromo saliendo hacia nosotros en el
espacio y en el otro estéreo y somero
hay un bromo lejos de nosotros en el
espacio tienen configuraciones opuestas
en ese carbono y luego en este carbono
vamos de iones aquí a una cuña acá de
manera que también hay configuraciones
opuestas en este carbono debido a que
tenemos configuraciones opuestas en
todos los centros finales esperaríamos
que estos sean en anti o menos uno del
otro
ahora bien qué ocurre con la relación
entre 1 y 2 en principio podríamos
pensar que ambos son enantiómero ya que
aquí tenemos una cuña y de este lado
tenemos guiones y aquí tenemos una cuña
y aquí tenemos guiones por lo que
tenemos configuraciones opuestas en los
dos centros finales por lo que estos
podrían ser en anti o menos
veamos el vídeo para ver si eso es
cierto en la izquierda está la molécula
uno con los dos bromo saliendo hacia
nosotros en la derecha está la molécula
2 con los 2 bramos lejos de nosotros si
girar de la derecha podemos ver que
estos son imágenes especulares uno del
otro pero son imágenes especulares
superponibles si pongo una encima de la
otra verás que se superponen así que
esto es en realidad son dos modelos de
la misma molécula este es un compuesto
mes o es un compuesto que tiene centros
quirales pero es a girar la imagen
especular es
ponible
así que 1 y 2 realmente representan a la
misma molécula esto es un compuesto mes
o un compuesto que tiene centro
espirales pero es shakira la imagen
especular es súper ponible pensamos que
teníamos cuatro historias o meros pero
en realidad sólo tenemos tres tenemos un
par de en anti o menos y un compuesto
mes o y para saber si a un compuesto es
mes o lo que podemos hacer es lo que
vimos en el vídeo donde teníamos la
imagen especular y pudimos superponer la
imagen especular sobre sí misma otra
manera de ver si un compuesto es mes o
es buscar un plano de simetría si dibujo
una línea aquí piensa en esto como un
plano y busca la simetría en ambos lados
puedes ver que la molécula es simétrica
dibuje el plano de simetría con una
línea punteada pero es difícil de
visualizar aquí arriba tenemos una
imagen mejor aquí se puede ver el plano
que divide a la molécula por la mitad en
el lado izquierdo tenemos nuestros
enlaces aquí y tenemos nuestro bromo que
va hacia arriba y nuestro hidrógeno que
va hacia abajo el lado derecho es
simétrico al lado izquierdo así que
busca que haya simetría en ambos lados
del plano
hagamos un ejemplo más este es un poco
más difícil que el anterior sabemos que
tenemos dos centros quirales este es un
centro quiral y también lo es este
así que esperaríamos tener dos a la
segunda potencia estéreo isómeros es
decir cuatro esther isómeros le voy a
poner signos de interrogación aquí de
nuevo porque no estamos seguros de si en
realidad obtendremos cuatro estéreo
isómeros este es el número máximo que
podríamos tener aquí están las cuatro
posibilidades 1 2 3 y 4 y vamos a
examinar la relación entre 1 y 2 primero
aquí está el stories homero 1 y no creo
que los hidrógenos del grupo metilo y en
lo h para poder ver los modelos mejor
aquí está nuestra cadena de carbono si
tenemos ambos saliendo hacia nosotros
para el estéreo -2 aquí está la cadena
de carbonos y ambos
se están alejando de nosotros
voy a sostener de la forma en la que
están dibujados y voy a girar el de la
derecha y podemos ver que estas son
imágenes especulares pero si trato de
superponer uno sobre el otro
voy a rotar este de aquí y voy a darle
la vuelta se puede ver que no coinciden
por lo que no son superponibles no
importa como lo coloques lo voy a girar
de nuevo y vemos que no podemos
superponer los átomos estas son imágenes
especulares no superponibles son
enantiómero podríamos buscar un plano de
simetría voy a tomar una de estas y
rotar la de manera que tengamos los
hidrógenos alejándose en nosotros busca
un plano de simetría pero no veo uno así
que esto no es un compuesto mes o
así que 1 y 2 son anti o menos son
imágenes especulares no superponibles
podríamos haber adivinado eso porque si
nos fijamos en nuestros centros
espirales este tiene un h que viene
hacia nosotros y luego éste tiene un h
alejándose de nosotros este tiene un h
que va hacia nosotros y éste tiene un h
que va lejos de nosotros tenemos
configuraciones opuestas en ambos
centros espirales echemos un vistazo a 3
y 4 ahora cuál es la relación entre
estos dos al principio podríamos pensar
que estos son en anti o menos porque en
este carbono hay un h en una cuña y aquí
tenemos un h con guiones y de este lado
tenemos un h con guiones y aquí lo
tenemos con una cuña por lo que esa
podría ser tu primera conjetura vamos a
ver el vídeo y echemos un vistazo a los
modelos moleculares para ayudarnos
recuerda que estoy emitiendo los
hidrógenos del grupo metilo y los
hidrógenos
en el vídeo solo para ayudarnos a ver la
molécula más claramente aquí está la
molécula 3 con su cadena de carbono con
un h lejos de nosotros y 1 h hacia
nosotros aquí está la molécula 4 con su
cadena de carbono 1 h saliendo hacia
nosotros y un h lejos de nosotros voy a
sostener los dos modelos y vamos a
compararlos primero vamos a ver si son
imágenes especulares así que voy a girar
el de la derecha y lo sostengo junto al
de la izquierda y ahora podemos ver que
estos dos son imágenes especulares vamos
a ver si son superponibles así que voy a
regresar la molécula como estaba al
inicio y veamos si podemos superponer la
de la derecha con la molécula en la
izquierda
observa que si se superponen todos los
átomos están alineados los hidrógenos
carbono y oxígeno están en los mismos
lugares
este es un compuesto que tiene centros
finales pero que es shakira a las
imágenes especulares son superponibles
así que debemos de ser capaces de
encontrar un plano de simetría escoger
uno de estos modelos no importa cual ya
que representan el mismo compuesto y voy
a girar la para que podamos ver un plano
de simetría justo aquí está nuestro
plano este es un compuesto mes o así que
3 y 4 en realidad representan el mismo
compuesto este es un compuesto mes o
estos dos son lo mismo y tenemos un
compuesto mes mirando a estas
estructuras de enlace línea no es muy
evidente que estos representan la misma
molécula por lo que te recomiendo
conseguir un modelo molecular e intentar
hacer este ejercicio por tu cuenta
pensamos que podría haber cuatro
esteroides o menos pero en realidad sólo
hay tres tenemos un par de en anti o
menos y tenemos un compuesto en eso